now when things happen whenever there's
a mass shooting or something immediately
people want to blame gun owners or
people that want to protect gun owners
and specifically NRA members this comes
down on you sometimes this always comes
out on me people that want guns and
people that don't want regulations and
don't want you know additional screening
yeah because you gotta think about it so
like the figureheads when you and you
start talking about Wayne and so there
people go after them clearly right but
then also you have the personalities of
the brand which is me Dana and Dana
laughs yeah Dana laughs right she's an
official spokesperson right very nice
lady matter exactly then you have cam
Edwards exactly yeah and so what had
what ends to happen is I get it a lot
via social because that's how I built my
brand mm-hmm right I built my band
through social and so most people will
when they can't descend like I don't
think Wayne LaPierre has a Twitter page
you know he doesn't have an Instagram
account right so it's probably the
bunker somewhere well your but what you
are is an interesting version of the NRA
it's like oh this is the NRA - this is a
kind of a new thing it's multi-faceted
like yeah if any I dare anyone to go to
the NRA in your meetings and then if you
can I don't know how secluded it's go to
the board meeting and you have a thinner
area meetings you'll be surprised they
have I have every race you can think of
different sexualities you name it oh I
believe you look I was in the NRA
forever I just might let my membership
lapse like a year and a half ago but I
was in the NRA because I just felt like
I know people that are just like we've
got to get rid of the guns I'm like man
I don't think that's gonna do it and I
don't think that's gonna stop anything
even and I actually possess all the
songs done it on my show I called the
big red button question right so he put
a big red button I'd ask him if I put a
big red button in the middle of table if
you push this button all the guns on the
planet disappear would you do it and and
I'll get various answers but I wouldn't
do it
and we were like wow like why would you
not happy the end of violence only not
real it's also the end of defense
exactly especially when you're talking
about military I mean if you can't if
you don't have guns like we're gonna
fight with swords and bows and arrows
and [ __ ] you know the interesting thing
about that too is only a lot of people
are this I will say they were like why
did the same people will say why do you
need an ar-15 and then in an inverse
when I say the Second Amendment is
actually not about hunting it's about
defending ourselves from a tyrannical
government domestic or foreign they're
like oh you think you little stupid guns
are gonna be able to defend against the
against the government I'm like well
then why don't you give me the guns that
the government has then and then they
get quiet because they realize the
contradiction and what they're stating
well it's also the government when you
say the government like protect us
against the government we are the
government the government is filled with
people like the cops are us the problem
is is this separation of us if you gave
me a red button said would I could I end
all senseless violence by hitting that
button I would say yes and then when
people say it's a guns promise do you
know that London past New York City for
the first time since 1800 in homicides
and they did it with [ __ ] knives with
knives to the point where that goofball
Mayor of London that dork on his Twitter
page said there's no reason to carry a
knife if you get caught carrying a knife
you'll be prosecuted under the fullest
extent of the law this is the [ __ ]
knife but I've got a knife all the same
country that the utilizes the shining
example of what we should be doing in
America exactly and they they have more
murders in London from knives and here's
the funny thing about that too you know
like and so they have an uptick in acid
attacks sorry I think I shot